hi hi there Steve Kaufman here again I'm
gonna talk a little bit today I got that
microphone a little closer sometimes I
get complaints that people can't hear
I'm gonna talk a bit again about stephen
krashen and some of the things that he
says about the importance of reading and
in language learning and in literacy and
it's spelling and in writing all of
these things depend on how much we read
according to crashing and I'm going to
post at my blog
the linguist on language blog some URL
some links to some of the work that
crashing has done now let me start off
by saying that you can probably find all
kinds of academic references and
research results to prove just about
everything when it comes to language
mark you can find their parts that say
that we should correct grammar mistakes
that we shouldn't the teacher
intervention help so that it doesn't
help so you know I treat these different
research results as arguments that I can
use and I select the ones that I like
and other people select the ones that
they like and so that's fair but there
is significant research by crashing and
others to support the idea that the most
important thing we can do in school is
to get children to read and the best way
to get them to read to improve their
reading skills is to somehow and use
them to read more and that all of the
teacher intervention about reading
skills and teaching them how to infer
things and so forth is largely a waste
of time if we can give them access to
books if we show them examples of people
reading if they're given time to read in
class which Craftsmen calls something
remember he's got an acronym for it just
let them read silent reading let them
read in class if we let them read things
that they're interested in and if they
if they're only interested in dragons or
in hockey players or whatever so let me
spend the time on that eventually their
interest will expand but people have
narrow interests in fact her not to be
more voracious readers because they're
interested in something and I would like
to add to crashing the importance of
listening which gets less attention but
the main way we pick up a language is
through listening if we spend two months
listening to nothing but one language we
had no access to any other language even
if we didn't understand the language we
would start to pick things up the brain
picks things up we are you don't learn
languages academically I wouldn't want
to listen to things that I don't
understand but there's research again
research out of New Zealand the shows
that if we sit around if we listen to
things even if we don't understand them
it does improve our ability to learn
language now of course I again go on
Google for listening and reading and lo
and behold the teachers have sort of if
there's a number I might even post some
references on my blog teachers have
discovered that listening is very
important in learning and it's been
neglected by the teachers and so now the
teachers want to get in there and teach
listening listening skills how we can
notice this and and turn something that
again should be an adorable task into
some kind of something that can be
taught and so that they can them ask
them questions and did you notice or did
you infer or where you focus to review
this and that and again that's not the
answer the answer is to give people
interesting things to listen to if it's
interesting if they like it if it's
largely understandable then they will
listen now what I have talked about
before and I want to stress and I don't
hear crashing saying it is that
listening can be tremendously important
to help people who have trouble reading
there is significant research to show
that kids who hear a lot of words and
and are exposed to the interesting
conversation at home have a tremendous
advantage when they start school and
those that don't have that kind of a
listing environment never ever catch up
regardless of all the efforts by
teachers to teach reading techniques and
all the other things that the critical
thinking or whatever it is that they
like to teach it doesn't have much
impact that that and the first crash is
interesting because he says rather than
teaching kids just let them sit there
and read and I think there's a lot of
wisdom to that and and this gets back to
the fact in language learning that so
often when we pick up textbooks and even
the starter books they're 90%
explanations the 90% teaching rules
exercises and only 10% content that you
can listen to and read what we really
need is 90% content to listen to them
read and 10% explanation and of course
that's what we try to do at Linc and we
try to provide some structure so that
you can actually learn the vocabulary we
will be introducing more explanation
that's to say that a lot of the teeth
tutors forums that are linked to
different content items which are now a
little bit difficult to find we hope
within a couple of weeks to place them
right below each lesson reached content
item that people are listening to in
reading and so therefore as various
native speakers and tutors chime in with
their grammatical explanations relevant
to this particular content on those will
accumulate a sort of like a wiki grammar
related to each particular content item
but still 90 percent content 90 percent
listening and reading 10 percent
explanation drill reading strategies and
so forth so that's really that what I
wanted to talk about I wanted to once
again focus attention on crashing
because I happen to come across these
these
papers and other bits of information
about reading and listening and just
have a look at how some teachers just
can't resist the temptation of trying to
make it more complicated than it really
is thank you for listening